hi again still look up I'm putting I'm
posting this new video concerning my
method of learning languages because
when people ask me to post it so I'm
glad that I'm going to do it but I even
prepared a written text which I'm going
to read the important thing right now is
that I get through the message of what
I'm learning I really want to say as far
as languages learning languages is
concerned and not showing how well I can
do in a language I'm going to read this
taxi and okay so now after posting some
videos we're at speak foreign languages
I was repeatedly asked to post one more
video concerning my way to learn them I
feel happy if I can mean in any way
helpful to the learning endeavors of
other language as suggests and honored
to know that some of you are actually
inspired by the videos that was great
when I was told that I'm knowingly
professor of course learning languages
is a pleasant hobby for me but I'm just
taking the liberty of sharing with you
some basic principles and some of what I
think would be good advice about the
overall learning process first of all
the introduction first of all learning
the language and getting to its master
it's not an easy task of course
everybody knows we're really not as
difficult as it may seem the idea that
learning language is a hard and long
process belongs to the group of what I
call the most commonly false but
accepted ideas I call this video an easy
way to learn because I was inspired by
the title of the book which turned out
to be very important in your life an
easy way to stop smoking by Alan Carr
which literally dismantled
reason why a bunch of smoke and render
CT quitting the cigarettes whereas the
active cleaning smells still generally
perceived as difficult I I quoted this
book because one is simply to be shown
how to do something and that will do it
much more easily than they might ever
ever imagined this works for languages
too of course it takes an effort to
learn and languages to learn language so
no matter what method you are using
there are some basic principles to
college the easy way to learn languages
based upon in which you have to stick to
the first principle is to work on a
daily basis or at least five days a week
known to get a no gigantic amount of
work is required just 30 minutes every
day one hour would be best for the first
three months it is much more effective
in the long run to learn every day a
little bit rather than spend two whole
days on books and audio CDs and do
nothing for the rest of the week we you
will be really astounded at the progress
you've made after some six months the
second principle is to learn in a
natural way as natural as possible this
way of getting into the real fabric of a
language doesn't contemplate the use of
horrible and had to come you know
horrible handy sounds of grammar which
everybody's scared of I'm not saying
that grammar books are not useful but as
far as I see it it is better is use them
as a point of reference for a thorough
linguistical studies eventually but not
in self teaching methods I personally
think that the use of these books might
turn out to be a discouraging sometimes
given its having it it is much better to
concentrate directly on the spoken
language by listening to dial on some
write down simple grammar and Alice
progressively there are some very coarse
is some some very good courses which
work is way in which I will quote later
the third principle is that learning the
language should not be a stressful event
but a very pleasant one of course
hopefully wherever you feel on your
stretchin if you will frustrate it
because you can't recall something you
just learnt a few days ago relax and
think that in some some time many of the
problems you were facing at that moment
will be a ridiculously keeping some time
later so what is it jets will learning a
language is to remember that it has to
be constant and natural and pleasant way
to learn of course my method is
concerned it is a strategy I perfected
and consolidated for time it is based
upon principles we just generated and
basically consists of three phases the
electric phase consists of listening to
dialogue repeating 70 times writing them
your native language and then re
translating them in language you're
learning later at a later stage you
first read for example you read the
first dialogue then and then repeat it
then the day after or some days later
you read the second one the second
dialogue and while doing this you write
down that look number one in your name
language the third day read again lesson
number two and try to translate lesson
number one by writing it down in the
language you're trying to learn we're a
little bit confusing it's not easy to
actually explain it but for further
explanation you can send me a message
and i'll
I ride down the way anyway oh right I
leave the text the steps we asked me
looking at you it's just a normal rock
pile I was saying it seems complicated
at the beginning that this process seems
a little complicated but it just
consists of terrible terrible operations
that you do at the same time on learning
language so the red part is the
fundamental key to the method because it
is they're literally fixes the structure
of the language in your brain through
the efforts of retranslated that
language of disks Fairport the space can
last a period arranged into three six
months declining how do you structure
your work I use all your schedule is
running down some grammar notes what
wouldn't be bad actually the second or
intermediate phase is very similar to
the elementary one just keep reading
listening running down a return flight
andrey translating dialects but this
base is integrated with slightly more
complicated texts which also have to be
written down in your name language can
be translated into the language you're
learning layer and then confront it with
original with the original version the
space lasts six months more or less
after you are doing this will be very
surprised and while you know from this
point on the effort you may learn is
incredibly reduced then you will you'll
find a much much easier and much better
to learn here start the event event
space at this point of course your
problem is finished and what you have to
do is simply watch movies with subtitles
in the
in spoken and spoken and the written
part they have to be in the language you
aren't learning even subtitles of course
after a year and a half two years max
but you course you it would be suitable
to also to read some newspapers and if
you don't understand everything it's not
a bad thing after a year and a half do
yours max would be good very good good
very good or excellent in the lens you
wanted to learn and it won't be a
miracle well it would be just reality
you know and anyone I repeat anyone can
do this
and guess what level of ecology a
delicate subject to talk about is
prioritization I personally think that
everybody can reach a good pronunciation
with with some effort and a good
presentation is very important to make
yourself understood and the level of the
pronunciation they reach depends on your
personal linguistical inclination in
year one I want to point out is that it
is extremely important to concentrate
and listen to the sound of the arrow at
the early stage of your learning it is
very very important it is not just a
matter of listening but also being able
to reproduce the sounds correctly
through the correct position on the
positioning of your tongue and this is
our piece is very important the native
speaker helping you in the process would
be great
and would accelerate the process of
acquiring or producing sounds correctly
but it is not strictly necessary and the
time it's the best fear lies in sense
that what you can pronounce correctly
now you will be able to do some time
later and much and much better in a much
better way the pronunciation consists of
two main phases of being able to
pronounce every syllable word correctly
and then concentrate on getting a proper
information of the sentence at later
stage also they're important especially
in languages life time I know people
that can't pronounce it who at corners
can't pronounce every single and telling
work very well but at same time when
they have to you know some make sense it
kind of gets a little bit messy as far
as information the concern in tongues
are important you know to give proper
information it's very important at a
time the methods which I use to get
appointed with a language is a small
book with audio CD called Peter salt
Peter solving English teacher self
Swedish and then I use the SML series in
with what I have to take the
intermediate level and of course a
resort to other material like to spend
with the movies at the advanced level
okay but this is more or less you know
the lines of what I do of course I
didn't I couldn't put details in it but
anyone who wants to ask me feel free to
ask anyway and remember that the more
languages you learn the easier it gets
to learn
languages and learning language opens
you know a lot of doors
really a lot of doors and gives you
insight into different incredible the
patterns of thought so I really really
thankful for listening to me and I and I
truly love I was in some way helpful to
you and if you have any more questions
or doubts please again feel free to ask
okay thank you